phonce napkin I'm watching like Nardo I
missed the whole plot line
smacking snack I can't eat with somebody
with somebody like that you break and I
find it on the show every time you get
rid of drop ten bro meet Mia two four
dude you know you should have took with
you fishing oh [ __ ]
really yeah man I was jealous wants all
those pictures there's two things you
want to do with chin what's what there's
two things you want to do with them he's
thinking the other one but it's if you
if you want to go eat cream barbecue
chin yep if you want to go fishing you
take this you want to hide a dead body
you call chin oh damn huh those three
thing yeah yeah
really what do you fish for chin
actually when I was looking at your
thing I fished for trout mostly so looks
like that's trot area yeah if the fresh
is a freshwater if yeah it's fresh water
pressure you can imagine mmm
so fresh drinking oh yeah you could pick
some up in his hand I love the free
water manage it would jump right any if
you even open your mouth up close about
six inches from the top of a lake
someone would jump oh yeah just that
Oregon [ __ ] River man food come and
write out the mountains beautiful middle
seat over there I feel like I'm on
Spirit Airlines [ __ ] my penis we got
chairs in here you got another one oh
hell no this the original the wheels
fall let's try another two outside
[Laughter]
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]